the left today has to be about uniting
people around their common Humanity
connected through with diversity
diversity is not an obstruction to Unity
and unity is not uniformity
so
organizing through our diversities
for the common good for the common good
of the planet for the common good of
society and
overcoming both this new polarization
that is economic of the one percent and
the 99
and the manufactured polarities in
society so that people are unable to
work together think together live
together that is transcending that is
the project of the left today
foreign
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
I have the distinct pleasure of sitting
today with bandana Shiva where I should
say Dr Vandana Shiva who is a physicist
an ecologist a feminist and a a leading
activist in is it fair to say
left-leaning circles
and left and all Progressive things yeah
marvelous
always trying to make the world a better
place for plants and animals and humans
that is a very uh Noble goal one I of
course share with you I should say I
became aware of your work some 15 years
ago a student Josephine Jarvis alerted
me to your work and I've been a fan ever
since
um
so from the point of view of what we
might discuss
um I think my audience should know that
you have your PhD is in
um
MSC honors and physics is in particle
physics particle physics took me to the
foundations of quantum theory so I went
to Canada
at the University of Western Ontario
where they actually had a program
dedicated to Quantum Theory and they had
attracted the best minds of the world
so I wrote to people in South Africa and
I wrote to people in Poland and wrote to
people in Australia and all of them were
at Western so that's where I did my PhD
on the foundations of quantum theory and
the topic of my PhD was hidden variables
and non-locality in quantum theory and
why is that important because no matter
what you try you can't bring determinism
into the quantum before we stay
uncertain and the second you cannot
bring separation in the quantum world it
is always entangled that's why an
unseparability in non-locality and these
were issues that fascinated me and have
continued to guide my thinking including
my work in agriculture my work in
ecology my work on reverse I always look
at it in the point of view of an
entangled world of interconnectedness
and non-separation and a world of
a little bit of unpredictable outcomes
we are thrilled to have Western razor
companies sponsoring this episode of
Darkhorse my grandfather Harry was a
chemist he worked on vinyl for long
playing records at RCA he worked on
Dental polymers and he worked at Schick
safety razor company
when I would visit him as a child I
would look through the Razer prototypes
he had kept these safety razors weren't
at all like modern razors they were
Hefty durable serious objects built to
last
years later when I began shaving I
forgot all about those old razors the
world was by then full of colorful
up-to-date options with pivoting heads
lubrication strips and multiple blades
ain't progress Grand
decades later I've come full circle it's
true that modern razors are better
better at getting you to spend a lot
more than necessary on shaving
pivoting heads that's a gimmick you are
supposed to adjust the angle of the
razor for the Contours of your face not
have the razor follow the path of least
resistance lubrication strips they work
at first but they exhaust themselves
quickly leading you to toss a razor that
still has life left in the blades and
speaking of blades how many do you
really need the fact is multiple blades
pack tightly together is just another
scam that Arrangement is guaranteed to
clog with hair and soap so you'll toss
it in the garbage and reach for another
if what you want is a close shave then
what you need is a no-nonsense shaving
instrument a safety razor from Western
Razor Company looks like a tool it feels
like a tool and it functions like a tool
because that's what it is no plastic no
gimmicks no hidden costs no
subscriptions you pay up front for a top
quality handle made entirely here in the
USA it comes with five double-sided
blades and when you need more top
quality blades are available for less
than 20 cents a piece
go to westernrazor.com Darkhorse and use
the promo code Darkhorse at checkout to
support the podcast get 10 off your
order and take a stand against the
propaganda Stranglehold of big shaving
again that's westernrazor.com Darkhorse
and use the promo code Darkhorse at
checkout
our second sponsor this week is Vivo
barefoot shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of feet not vivos these aren't the
brainchild of some footless corporate
vampire squid vivos are made by people
people with feet who know how to use
them and Vivo shoes are a revelation
here at Dark Horse we love these shoes
they are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're fantastic our feet
are the product of millions of years of
evolution humans evolve to walk move and
run Barefoot but modern shoes that are
overly cushioned and strangely shaped
have negatively impacted foot function
and are contributing to a Health crisis
one in which people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
Vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases sixty
percent in a matter of months just by
walking around in them the number of
people wearing Vivo barefoots is growing
once people start wearing these shoes
they don't seem to stop
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
as well as everyday wear they're a
certified B Corp pioneering regenerative
business principles and their Footwear
is produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild on it go to
vivobarefoot.com Darkhorse to get an
exclusive 20 off additionally all new
customers get a hundred day free trial
so you can see if you love them as much
as we do that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com slash
Darkhorse our final sponsor for this
episode is element that's lmnt
we evolved in an aqueous saline
environment we come from Salt Water it
is essential to us and we carry a
version of that environment around with
us everywhere we go but our modern lives
disrupt it
element is an electrolyte drink mix that
has everything you need and nothing you
don't it's got a lot of salts a thousand
milligrams of sodium 200 milligrams of
potassium 60 milligrams of magnesium but
it has no sugar no coloring no
artificial ingredients no gluten no
fillers
electrolytes facilitate hundreds of
functions in the body including the
conduction of nerve impulses hormonal
regulation and nutrient absorption
element can help prevent and eliminate
headaches muscle cramps and
sleeplessness
we have now heard from several friends
independently of one another about how
much they like element for themselves or
in some cases for their significant
others they drink it every day and feel
better doing so
When you sweat the primary electrolyte
lost is sodium athletes can lose up to 7
grams per day element is formulated to
help anyone with their electrolyte needs
and is perfectly suited to folks
following Aikido low carb or Paleo Diet
element is not just for athletes though
anyone being active can find that they
benefit from element even drinking a few
glasses of wine can leave you depleted
an element can help if you're feeling
depleted or dehydrated drink water and
consider element as well
right now element is offering our
listeners a free sample pack with any
purchase that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order this
is a great way to try all eight flavors
and share element with a salty friend
get yours at drinkelement.com Darkhorse
this deal is only available through our
link
you must go to
d-r-i-n-k-l-mnt.com Darkhorse
element offers no questions asked
refunds as well
try it totally risk-free if you don't
like it they will simply give you your
money back no questions asked you have
nothing to lose
I must say this is not my area of
expertise but I do find that there is
something utterly fundamental in that
tiny little bit of uncertainty because
if it is not true uncertainty then the
universe means something very different
and you for example my my area of
specialty is evolutionary biology and
evolutionary biology uh is
almost a a cosmic joke if there is not
uncertainty about the outcomes of
interactions
absolutely absolutely anything alive
and evolving
from within you know from its own
self-organization has always multiple
parts and the minute there's multiple
possibilities
you never have predictability you have
possibilities and possibilities then
create the uncertainty and
unpredictability which is the quality of
an evolving world
yes
um all right so
you have expertise in particle physics
especially entanglement and uncertainty
that's uh fascinating I'm not sure how
far down that road I can uh I can go in
a discussion but
um but it is at least there for us
um you have also worked extensively on
issues of genetic modification of
organisms GMOs and you have been a an
opponent of GMOs this is a place where
you and I overlap
um I I will say I feel a strong pressure
amongst scientists to Parrot a
particular Party Line the party line is
humans have been modifying organisms for
10
000 years this is nothing special and we
shouldn't be overly concerned just
because uh it's being done
scientifically now and this is of course
a nonsense position
the modifications that are being made uh
a have not been tested by selection in
other words if we compare something
that our ancestors may have modified and
then we are still using it thousands of
years later we know something about its
likely safety profile if something was
invented 10 minutes ago uh in a
laboratory we have no idea what it's
long-term effects are what's more many
of the most prominent modifications that
have been made to date are really about
um making organisms
uh ready for a pesticide heavy
environment and so really the idea the
genetic modification is uh leading
people to a false sense of security
about pesticides that really they should
not have I wonder if you would uh would
talk us through a deeper
um understanding of GMOs and where we
are now and and how you see that fight
going
well you know GMOs and genetic
engineering is often called the second
Green Revolution
and what was the first Green Revolution
it was the introduction of chemicals in
agriculture in countries like mine which
till then were organic ecological
after the wars
there was a lot of build up of chemicals
which the industry which had evolved
these chemicals to kill people in
concentration camps
IG farm and standard oil Monsanto with
buyer the same Partnerships that we see
again in our times
well after the wars instead of wrapping
up their factories they said let's
rework the chemicals to be agrochemicals
and now tell the world that you can't
have food without these chemicals
I was
to look at what the Green Revolution was
because in 1980
Punjabi had done my MSC honors in
particle physics which was a prosperous
state it was a peaceful state it erupted
in violence you know thousands of people
were killed in the violence and that
same year in 1984 the city of Bhopal had
a leak of a pesticide plant
owned by Union gabai then by Dao now but
thou has become merged with Dupont and
they are now called cultiva it sounds so
wonderful
well that's what compelled me to look at
why are we using these chemicals in
agriculture and where did it come from
and then I realized it came from more
Rachel Carson wrote about it in her book
Silent Spring and we're just celebrating
60 years of her writing of it Albert
Howard wrote about it in his book the
agricultural Testament
and so I dug deeper and deeper and
deeper because of that book I started to
get invited to meetings
on biotechnology and at a particular
meeting in 1987 in Geneva
the chemical industry was there and they
were now talking about GMOs and
patenting they said we have to do do
genetic engineering because it's our
only route to claim a patent on seed the
objective was not the engineering itself
their objective was Monopoly ownership
over life
and I realized you know I felt this is
so wrong C doesn't get invented in a lab
see there's a continuity of evolution as
you know so well
I also was troubled by the fact that
these companies said we'll be four by
the turn of the century and sure enough
therefore
and
just two of them syngenta and Baya which
is which is also Monsanto
Now controls 40 of the seed supply of
the word
so 87 I decided I was going to save
seeds
and I just started to save seats I
started to also participate I was asked
by my government to advise them on the
biodiversity negotiations which were
taking place in the late 90s which then
led to the convention on biological
diversity and I remember I was at the
Earth Summit and I've written it about
it in my book Terra Viva my life in a
biodiversity of movements that's been
published by Chelsea Green
I talked to every government that was
there at Rio in 92.
and talked about what genetic
engineering was and that it would have
impacted biodiversity and therefore a
convention on biodiversity should have a
clause to look at that impact that's
science so we managed to introduce an
article 19.3 in the convention on
biological diversity
the United Nations realized that I was
about the only one in Civil Society
talking about this so they asked me to
help with an expert group to frame a
convention on biosafety which is the
science of assessing the impact of
genetically engineered organisms on the
environment and biodiversity on public
health and now it also includes the
socio-economic conditions of farmers
when we managed to get a Cartagena
protocol
[Music]
of course the corporations weren't happy
because every time
you know there was a rotating revolving
door between the U.S government and
Monsanto and one time it would be a
government representative next time it
would be Monsanto and because I'd seen
all this in continuity now I was always
there to challenge you for example they
introduced Roundup Ready seeds as
Brilliant Invention that prevents the
weeds from stealing the sunshine
the sun shines in such abundance for all
life on Earth and at least in my ecology
there is nothing like a weed it is just
mismanagement of Good Farming you know
in Good Farming there are no pests and
there are no weeds there are lots of
insects and there are lots of plant
diversity and we have a huge movement in
India with the peasant women of bringing
back the wild uncultivated crops
particularly in these times of climate
Havoc you know in a storm can wipe out
your cultivated crop but all those
greens are still surviving and that's
what has happened again and again after
climate disasters so the bio safety law
was put in place in India we already had
a law
and Monsanto came to India illegally in
1998.
that with arrogance put their
announcement in newspapers I rang up my
Ministry of environment I said did you
give them approval because we had a law
I asked the Ministry of Agriculture I
said did you give an approval because
they too were supposed to test seeds
neither of them had even heard about
Monsanto or BT cotton so
I filed a case against Monsanto and the
government for sleeping I said you are
supposed to prevent this kind of
unregulated entry and that case actually
is still going on but we managed to
delay the commercialization
so when you ask me what do I think about
genetically modified organisms on the
ethical cosmological level it basically
means god move over we will now pretend
to be creators
the second thing
I found over time with my research and
I've written about it in my book Oneness
versus one percent which is also being
published by Chelsea Green
lies that
the same
thinking that had created the chemical
industry in the first place big Pharma
big chemicals the collaboration of
Rockefeller through Standard Oil and
igfab and the cartel in Germany
that actually when the Nazis moved to
the United States
a whole new discipline was born
and it's it's written about in a
brilliant book based on the archives of
the Rockefeller Foundation the book is
called the molecular vision of Life
House biology was reduced to determinant
molecules where they at that time they
didn't even have the gene but they said
molecules atoms of determination or
basically inferiority of women
of colored people people with black hair
you know because it was treating the
human beings as blonde with blue eyes
and Men
well that book by Lily k
shows you how it isn't the case that
this reduction is biology evolved in an
in a scientific way through Democratic
debates
among scientists molecular biology was
imposed by the very same people who
imposed chemicals on the world so you
know the chemicals were the first
generation and genetically engineered
organisms were the second generation and
just like chemical pesticides have
failed to control pests and chemical
fertilizers have actually destroyed soil
fertility rather than help with soil
fertility
the number of pets that have grown with
the use of chemical pesticides is huge
thousands of percent more pests today
but with genetic engineering initially
you know they were going to save the
world they were going to going to plant
food on the moon they were going to grow
food in the Sahara they were going to
grow food on toxic dumps because GMOs
would do everything and at the end of
that propaganda they just had two traits
the traits you talked about traits to
have more chemicals Roundup resistant
crops are designed to sell more Roundup
look at the data in the United States
yeah
huge percentages of increase of Roundup
and the BT toxin crops were supposed to
control pests what is the result after
this 30-year experiment
Roundup Ready crops have created
superweeds and round and BT toxin drops
have created super pests they have
failed as a technology they are bad
science because the science of living
systems is complex
about interaction it is not about
molecules of determination and it has
gone very wrong but the tragedy is that
because GMOs are related to patterns
patent monopolies have allowed the
poison makers to become the seed
controllers of the world and that is the
dangerous thing that they are interested
in selling more toxics they're
interested in spreading more cancer
they're interested in killing mobile
diversity
they will not
on their own without a huge Democratic
revolt
respond to the needs of the earth and
the needs of people I have just this
evening been with the environment
minister of Mexico
in a conference and Mexico as you might
know has said we will phase out
glyphosate and we will not allow GMO
corn
bear being hugely pressurized including
by the Corn Growers of
you know of the US who are actually
extensions of what I call the boys in
cartel why when I call them the poison
cartel I said what do they make poisons
how do they organize democratically no
as a contact behind the scenes
manipulating governments so GMOs have
have totally failed and now trying to
pretend that the new generations of GMOs
through Gene editing will be more
successful is even more of an error
because you know life is not a Microsoft
Word program where you can cut and paste
that is such a wrong conception
the tragedy is the the power of big
money and Monopoly connected to control
over science and connected to control
over media and public relations that is
what allows the lie that GMOs Feed the
World to be repeatedly told and believed
by ordinary people who don't look
closely at what's really going on
so I'd like to unpack uh a number of
themes in what you've said
one of the concerns that I have is that
biology is so complex
that even those of us who understand it
comparatively well because we've spent
our our lifetimes studying it are just
at the very edge of comprehension
there's so much unknown in biology that
it is effectively inevitable that uh it
will often upend your plans
um you know no matter how carefully
you've laid them out because of uh the
Dynamics in play
the problem though is that we have
Nations and laws that are not up to the
challenge of addressing that complexity
the only conceivable way that you could
do it is to set a precautionary standard
and have people who are completely
immune from Financial corruption
evaluating uh the hazards known and
unknown
uh that are contained in any given
proposal
and because industry stands to lose so
much financially if the public exerts
control in its own interest what they've
done is they've unhooked the apparatus
that would do that evaluation our
universities do not function as far as I
can tell science is
um an afterthought it's a it's a
marketing Ploy more than it is a method
right I don't see that method being
applied inside of universities very much
anymore what I see is technology being
portrayed as science and this is a very
alarming Trend and it is also one that
uh well I wonder what you will what you
will tell me but I must say as many
successes as there have been in waking
people to for example uh the dangers of
glyphosate
um overall I think people sense that
technology marches on and that the
present is constantly revealing new
breakthroughs that are marvelous that
um that attitude applied to biological
modifications is a recipe for disaster
and there's just no there's no
meaningful breaking force
you know I mentioned the biosafety laws
now most countries put them in place
Europe has it that's why Europe has not
been overtaken by GMOs except the
imported GMO Sawyer for animal feed but
not food
India outside that one GMO PT cotton
which also entered illegally there has
been no second crop they tried a BT
eggplant and we Rose against it in our
government held public hearings and I
think it's the first time in world
history that there were public hearings
around a vegetable and the vegetable one
and Monsanto lost and there was a
moratorium put on on the introduction of
their plant there's an uh trying they're
trying very hard to put a GMO mustard
and and they haven't yet managed
okay on the issue of glyphosate
so many governments
want to ban it but every time a step it
is taken
the ministers involved are sacrificed
the minister of
Mexico who introduced that decree
because here his house was broken into
and he said this is costing my life
was the Imam and Minister said to the
president I will work one for one year
but if you don't ban glyphosate I
believe and he had to leave because they
didn't ban life or say
so
I'm you're so right
that
corporations and Industry find tools
find tools of manipulation find tools
that facilitate the Monopoly
and
and they push those tools as science
but the tools are not working to deliver
on what they're supposed to the example
of Roundup Ready crops creating super
weeds so now you have dicamba if you
have other herbicide causing havoc in
the United States is the only country
that doesn't have a GMO regulatory
system
it doesn't have a regulatory system
and
why why do you think that is
well I'll remember I remember so clearly
you know because I'd worked so hard with
governments who introduced article 19.3
President Bush Senior
refused to sign the convention on
biological diversity he said I will not
have my 50 billion dollar industry sunk
through regulation
so he came back and then his vice
president if I remember was a Dan whale
who could not
spell potato if I remember right
but he
created the whole system
of what they call substantial
equivalence they said pretend pretend
that a GMO is like its parent and
therefore you don't have to look you
don't have to see because it's all
natural
so he you know substantial equivalence
was introduced into the United States
system to basically say we'll never look
we'll never find and then of course a
parallel move was taking place in the
universities where public universities
were totally a normal public
you will now have to raise your money
and you'll have to do it by working for
corporations you'll have to do work to
bring them intellectual property rights
and that turned the universities into
basically intellectual slaves of the
corporate world that's where science
disappeared
and propaganda substituted it I I agree
with this and you know in some sense
evolutionarily speaking
you get whatever creatures the niche
will support and the the economic
environment surrounding University
Research effectively guaranteed that it
would become subordinate to corporate
power but because that was not the
original intent of University science
people have a hard time understanding
how corrupt it has has become even
people involved in it don't realize the
extent to which uh their conclusions are
foregone because uh were they to run
afoul of corporate power
um they would find themselves defunded
um
but well there are a couple places that
I think would be worth going one I think
we would be remiss if we did not at
least mention
that
um covid is in some sense the greatest
argument against genetically modified
organisms that one could possibly
imagine that the evidence which is now
in my opinion quite overwhelming that
this virus was
enhanced and modified uh in a laboratory
presumably the laboratory in Wuhan
um means that this is a genetically
modified organism and one thing it has
done is it has demonstrated uh that you
are playing with a kind of biological
power that uh you know we are able to
enhance the infectivity but we are not
able to manage control once the virus
has escaped so
um you know as strange as it sounds
I think really the battle over covid and
the battle over
um genetically modified organisms are
one our one story
um
yes because life is a Continuum and the
laws of Life are a Continuum whether
it's viruses or bacterials seeds and
plants or human beings
and and now that the landsat
on the origins of corvid and Jeffrey
Sachs was the chair has come out so
clearly
saying it was
a Lab Escape
it wasn't a market it wasn't a wet
Market I think you're getting very
conservative groups
recognizing that this was genetically
engineered
and it's an Escape
and and there needs to be accountability
accountability of those who funded this
totally Reckless research because it is
biological Belfair you know it's a tool
of biological warfare to try and
actually design viruses that harm
and you know you don't do it in a in a
society where you don't want to cause a
harm
to deliberately want to use the tools of
biological manipulation to cause harm is
biological warfare
and
and I think so much is now coming out of
the very tight little group you know
which is running all this faking the
signs
taking public money and siphoning on for
anti-people research and and I think it
should be a wake-up call for how
how life and biological systems have to
be kept in the comments of the common
good not become
tools for
harming other countries people and then
of course having no control and no
systems or bringing it back because
there is in GMOs once it's released
there's nothing like a recall
decide you can ban it with the GMO once
it's out it's out so
I think between the failure of the cgmos
and the high cost
of
the virus GMO
it is time for society as a whole to
take stock of how do we want to govern
ourselves will we allow a tiny Clique of
profiteers
to run the show will they be Beyond
accountability and we'll still call it
democracy democracy is when people
lead it is not when Crooks played yeah
and in fact the covet story
um makes all of this so clear because
you know there was a ban on gain of
function research in the United States
and Anthony fauci circumvented it the
reason that the research was happening
in Wuhan was that he offshored it to
circumvent a democratic ban because
certain people were properly alarmed by
the hazard of
um of the enhancements that were being
proposed
so it is a story that reveals as you say
a tiny click of people held the fate of
the world in their hands and
um not only did they unleash a
terrible virus one that I believe
actually
um you know the argument for the
research was that it was in danger that
a closely related virus was in danger of
Leaping to humans at any time and we
needed to come to understand it so that
we could counteract it and so there the
implication is that we didn't understand
it well enough soon enough that we might
have prevented it which is of course
nonsensed I think it was very unlikely
to jump that Gap without human help we
provided that help
and then
for reasons that you know at best were
about corporate greed we botched the
response where it might have been
controlled in the early days we might
have actually been able to uh prevent a
permanent endemic State for the virus we
failed to do it and you know what a
Calamity I I don't know how much damage
has already been done economically I
know that the estimates of loss of life
are something like 6 million already but
with a virus that is now apparently
going to be a permanent fellow traveler
of humanity the costs are literally
incalculable and
um we can't continue
even if it was simple hubris that
resulted in this we cannot have uh
Humanity subjected to this level of
disaster as the result of the hubris of
a tiny number of people
um all right that's all right yes that
said
it is inconceivable to me having spent
many several decades now thinking about
the structure of governance
it is almost inconceivable to me that
the uh the necessary structures could be
um
empowered to put control back where it
belongs and and to establish some sort
of reasonable precaution about these
Technologies uh that I think it was at
one time possible but our systems have
been so
um
corrupted by these forces it's just hard
for me to imagine how we even get there
I'm hoping you'll tell me you see a way
no we have to clb we have to see a way
because
you know at the fact that there is a
system of control and irresponsibility
and Limitless greed
uh
we have to find new ways to organize
to
regenerate the power of the people which
is the only pie in democracy
this change will not come from the top
it will not come because suddenly a
brilliant new president
sees
it all clearly because sadly politics is
now so married
to corporations you know what we really
have is a corporate State everywhere and
the corporate state
will not bring the changes
to regulate the corporations so we need
much more
of solidarity among people and across
countries and I can say this much that
every time we've organized
across borders we when we've organized a
Beyond silos
has had effect you know it was being
said that the World Trade Organization
which was pushing the pattern tissue
which is putting the GMO issue on the
world
they had called it the constitution of
the world that now onwards the world
will be one Global Market and National
governments won't matter National
democracies and assemblies won't matter
parliaments won't matter
and we organized and reorganized as ifg
and uh yeah I'll be organized in Seattle
we had planned about 5 000 people will
come more than 30 000 people came and
this stopped the WTO
now of course after that the military
response has become much worse
and now the surveillance Technologies
are playing the role of the police
so how do we deal with unaccountable
power
that's where for me
the lessons of our freedom movement in
India becomes so important
the British Empire controlled 85 percent
of the territories of the world
and they got their control through
controlling the textile industry and
cotton and they grabbed the land of the
indigenous people in the Americas they
called the Africans made them slaves to
grow the cotton and be cotton Pickers
and then they Charmed their factories in
Manchester and Lancashire to be the
dumpers
of fabric all over the world destroying
local textile economies
so what did Gandhi do
he did three things
he said we've got to govern ourselves
and he called it swaraj and if you look
at that period in every country there
was movements for home rule yeah
including I I've been in in Hawaii for
the to stop the GMOs
and they had a home rule movement it was
people in the home rule movement that
were fighting GMOs
so we go to govern ourselves and
governing ourselves means they've got to
learn
to have the governing systems within us
yeah that means we have to know what
being human is about we have to know
what the power of a conscious human
being is and when many conscious human
beings work together that is the kind of
power that brings change the second is
we have to learn
to reclaim our economies
just because at that time only England
made the textiles to dump
well Gandhi said I'm going to spend
clock and the whole country started to
spin cloth and I took inspiration from
the spinning wheel say today's spinning
wheel is the seed that time the British
Empire was around cotton today the
Empire is over life
and where is life in the seed so
save your seeds we've created 150
community seed banks in India
we managed to pass laws that say seeds
and plants and animals are not human
inventions
absolutely
scientific biology and ethical
recognition that we are in our family
growing your food
having community and notice behind you
is I think a kitchen yes yes and I think
food growing your food and cooking your
food is the most revolutionary act in
today's time because food is what is
being controlled from the seed
to earlier junk food but now Mr Gates
wants fake food and he wants to convert
agriculture into a raw material supply
of carbohydrates and protein for totally
lab-made food
and Baya has said oh all this will
create bigger markets for us and we'll
have bigger Farms with using more
glyphosate using more fertilizers which
will then worsen the ecological problem
the third which is the most important
and to me the most powerful
the idea of satyagre
Satya is truth
our gray is the force of Truth now when
you know the truth
then the force of Truth is to not obey
untruth
to not participate in it
to detach yourself from it
so if you want to detach from GMOs what
do we do grown on GMO food create
communities and food economies and
they're growing they're growing hugely
they're growing very very fast we need
to do the same with health
to have a deeper awareness of what is
health you know the word immunity was
being made illegal during the covet
crisis as if there's nothing like an
immunity in a living system as if plants
don't have their resilience as if human
beings don't have their resilience and
there was an attempt to make it look
like we are all empty containers waiting
for the toxics to be poured into us
so Saturday in our times is to
understand the untruth
that's being built and live our truth
and live it with compassionate courage
live it with deep deep deep
Consciousness and live it with the
recognition that truth will always win
in the long run
well I certainly hope your rights
um it does bring me to a kind of a an
awkward topic but I think I think you're
the right person to discuss it with you
mentioned the WTO protests which of
course at the time I had sympathy before
um I later participated in uh the Occupy
Rebellion because I had great sympathy
for it I watched that one from the
inside descend into a kind of anarchist
Madness right at just an utterly useless
uh kind of a protest counterproductive
in fact and that has only gotten worse
in the U.S and seemingly it has spread
to at least other parts of the West
um
and I guess the question is this I've
been uh
proudly a member of the left for my
whole life
I still consider myself uh
a liberal in fact I say that I'm a
reluctant radical I know that only
radical change can save us but I know
how dangerous radical change is and so
I'm not happy that we have to face
radical change but I don't recognize
um a left that I can be part of I feel
like at best there are people on the
left who still make sense who are
isolated from each other and largely
rejected by the mainstream
um self-identified
liberal movement
that is a tremendous obstacle to the
kind of uh Awakening and the uh
recapture of power that you're talking
about we need a left to articulate a
vision of how the world might function
that isn't either utopian
or an excuse for some other kind of
authoritarian
nonsense so maybe you see something
different from from India but is there a
left
well you know we have one state where
there's a left governing and I would in
a few days have been there to address
the left uh but I I you know I have a
course to teach at the Earth University
and I want to tell your listeners uh you
know we learn how to make change
from nature we learn how to make change
from biodiversity because they are
changing all the time in very radical
ways you know for me one of the most
inspiring things is in the middle of a
cement a plant will come out and that is
the kind of resilience and creativity we
need
to know that if a plant can go through
the concrete
we too can go through the concrete of
authoritarianism concrete of total
corporate power
which is now becoming even worse as I've
written in my world Oneness verse about
the person because the corporations are
now owned by big money you know across
the syngentas coca-colas apples
all of them most of the investment is
from the asset management funds which
holds all the big money the black rocks
and the vanguards
they are driving the show so when you
ask about the Left To Me the left
[Music]
is about Justice
you know what did Marx talk about you
know Surplus accumulation what is
Surplus it can be extracting the rewards
that should return to society if they
were coming back to society all
societies would be prosperous there
would be no hunger there would be no
poverty there would be no unemployment
but most people forget that you know the
early thinkers and writers were always
talking ecology
yeah the metabolic Rift the
the organic founder of organic chemistry
leaving
who is you know all recited as the
person who
helped us build chemical fertilizers no
he disowned them I I recently wrote it
forward to a book of his published in
1887 or something in German and they've
just brought out an English version and
they asked me to write the forward so I
read the English version It's called The
Law of recycling
and he's talking about how all of nature
is about recycling there's nothing like
extraction he's the one who first used
the term metabolic Rift that there's a
metabolic Rift taking place between
humans and nature between the country
and the town and Marx picked it up from
there the metabolic Rift the separation
that's what it means not only does it
mean that you are separate but because
you are getting separate the umbilical
cord that maintains the metabolism of
society of ecosystems of organisms that
starts to collapse so I think if today
we have to have growing space for the
left we have to realize that ecological
movements that have Justice in them
they are trying to do what were all
movements of Justice have done second
to me reclaiming the comments
is left the left today and the regaining
Commons movement has to grow not only
because people want it but it'll become
necessary to survive
when your energy is taken away as it's
being done in Europe when your food is
taken away yeah how will you survive
you've got to get together and reclaim
the commons and and I think the idea of
occupy was powerful if the organizing
capacity was weak and also the FBI got
into it but you know the fact that
some attempts fail doesn't mean the idea
and the principle should be given up
but I agree I mean there there's a
reason that I still basically even if I
found that I was the only person still
speaking left principles I wouldn't
change my belief that there are the
correct ones but what I see is
um
an abandonment
of the
the path in some sense the left
succeeded
it took many ideas that were once
radical and they became mainstream these
were ideas that were about
uh justice and about
um a a wise view of ecology right these
things became bedrock in the west such
that they are now defended by
conservatives interestingly and the
self-proclaimed left has now instead of
looking at the West as having the
correct idea about a productive vibrant
sustainable society that
distributes uh its productivity fairly
which does not mean evenly but fairly
right instead of seeing it as a flawed
prototype seeing it as a system that
fails to live up to certain uh values
that it espouses
the left here at least in in the U.S is
now attacking that system as if its
flaws invalidate and I don't know how we
recover from that I think what we have
is a prototype that's very good and
fixing its flaws ought to be a priority
but attacking it is going to result in a
system it's going to be reversion to the
mean we're going to have a system that's
much less fair and
um I don't know how to wake the left to
that to that Danger
well you know I think part of of our
challenge really is and taking Evolution
seriously is new forms of the left will
emerge which will not be labeled as left
but will carry within them
the principles
and I think that new diversity
is where we have to look for
yes
you know because you know what what was
really what was W2 what was
globalization globalization was the
cooperation stay in America
but they Outsource the production
so the Ordinary People of the America
lost out in every way and that's where
the disenfranchisement then shifts
people
to
substituting
the
right to work their right to have food
their right to have shelter their right
to have Community all that then gets
substituted
by manufactured negative identity
is now leading to the divide and Rule
that is infecting every society in a
serious way so to me the left today has
to be about uniting people around their
common Humanity
connected through with diversity
diversity is not an obstruction to Unity
and unity is not uniformity
so organizing through our diversities
uh for the common good for the common
good of the planet for the common good
of society and
overcoming both this new polarization
that is economic of the one percent and
the 99
and the manufactured polarities in
society so that people are unable to
work together think together live
together that is transcending that is
the project of the left today
it should be
um I I would refer back to an earlier
point of viewers uh which I think is
um not well understood by most people
which is that when you have control over
for example
um the seeds that produce a large
fraction of the food that is consumed by
people you have a tremendous amount of
power over them whether you know as long
as the seeds are planted that power is
not evident but those who control those
seeds have
um a lever that is uh well beyond what
the you know the Demons of the 20th
century had dreamed of really absolutely
absolutely reaches precisely why I
started the movement of Daniel about
which I've talked in my book on the
biodiversity of movements in Tel Aviva
the beginning with one seed you can
reclaim this uh you know you claim your
freedom and the comments and I mentioned
the 150 community seed bags those
community seed banks have helped farmers
jump back after a cyclone
uh in the drought years the drought
resistant crops have allowed Farmers to
have food
so
you know from my own life
saving a seed is saving the freedom
saving the potential
of creating abundance
and saving the power
to share
that to me is thinking of the left the
ability to share rather than the ability
to monopolize because there's an
extractive economy that takes and takes
and takes and there's a solidarity
economy an economy of care that I call
an economy that takes everyone into
account every species into account and
at least from my work I have seen
everyone does better now we grow more
food Farmer's incomes come up the
ecosystems thrive on our farm we have
six times more butterflies than in the
forest our water levels have come up 70
feet by not exploiting the water but
giving water back to the soil so saving
a seed a little seed I think that is
very very powerful and no matter what
the laws in which country I think
everyone should do two things
save a seed grow it in your windowsill
even if you don't have a garden just
take one pot and one plant because it
re-establishes your relationship and
through that re-established relationship
you have a different sense of who you
are and what the world is and the second
if you can grow a garden
um I quite like this
um for multiple reasons I mean not only
is there the demonstration of of power
and the reconnection with something
ancient in the growing of a seed but
there's also you know if you just stop
to think about what it means you know
that you have this little object maybe
in like a little pebble and that somehow
it contains the necessary information to
extract from the soil and from the air
the materials necessary and it has the
information to build this you know a
miraculous of tree right a tree from
thin air that that is you know a miracle
except in one regard which is that we
have some understanding of how it works
some understanding but you know I think
it's amazing that most people
probably spend their entire life from
birth to death and they never spend
five minutes thinking about what it
means that that seed contains
information sufficient to cause a tree
to happen on its own without
intervention right that's that's an
amazing thing
um and I you know maybe that's part of
what you're saying about reconnection
um yeah reconnection and re recognizing
the potential you know boom a Quantum
physicist with whom I would have worked
but I worked with his student he talked
about the implicant order you know the
order within that unfolds
yeah and he was of course talking about
Quantum phenomena but in that seed is
the implicit order of the tree it's all
in there yeah and that and that power
is the power of life and living systems
and you know I'm just working on
um a new manuscript and
I realized that there's so much
connection between the quantum thinking
and evolutionary thinking the power of
the seed
Schrodinger Quantum physicist inspired
by Indian thought
started to look more deeply at living
systems and he has a little book called
what is life
and he says life unlike machines you
know machines create entropy the more
they grow the more entropy you have
living systems reverse entropy because
they create organized order
you know and and that is at the you know
Mr Gates has just talked about GMOs as
magical seeds no that's not the magical
part you know the the power of the sea
to become the crop to become the tree
that is the true
uh you know holding of life
shooting a gene in blindness editing
genes in ignorance that is not magic
it's ignorance
it's ignorance and it is also uh such a
woeful misrepresentation
the fact is
even those with this power to edit genes
uh or to splice them in
do not have the knowledge to write any
useful gene they couldn't write a single
one they don't speak the language and so
okay you've done something impressive
you've taken a gene from here and you've
put it in that organism that it didn't
exist in I I get it but the fraction of
The Wonder of that seed that is actually
the result of the editing is essentially
zero and the idea that this is your
scene because you edited that Gene in is
preposterous on its face if you
understand the the genetic underpinnings
of of uh what it is to be a seed makes
no sense
um but
uh I I fear that people just can't grasp
it that they don't realize that what is
being taken from them is their world
they live in a world of plants that
reproduce themselves and animals that
reproduce themselves and they're being
handed uh some sort of uh
technologically modified version and
they don't realize what they're giving
up
you know I just have a at the navdania
farm I have a group of visitors who come
from around the world who are Seed
Savers and they've come to interact with
navdanya and I think all of us could
become Seed Savers learn from the seed
learn the power of the seed you know
that if we start thinking of ourselves
as seeds we realize we have a lot of
power
if the seed can become a tree if we
think of ourselves as seeds we can have
the kind of power that is needed to make
the change we need to see
um I I would uh I would add to that that
Evolution has
um made some uh
it has taken an expedient route in a
couple of ways that have not served us
well in modern times
one of them is
that it caused us to be focused on
ourselves as individuals because our
ancestors only had a certain amount of
ability to affect things there was no
reason to understand one's descendants
10 Generations down the road because
there was no ability to affect their
world one way or the other one could
only affect things very locally which
created this uh
focus on the self but what we really are
is a very temporary conscious custodian
of something much more long-standing and
durable and we can screw it up in a
single generation but our job really is
to keep the experiment going as long as
possible to deliver the experience that
we have of life to as many descendants
as can experience it and to deliver it
to them not just the fact of life but to
deliver them
a healthy planet on which to live out
their lives to deliver them A system
that frees them to do with their life
something meaningful and we are because
we are so obsessed with our current
selves because we are obsessed with
ourselves as individuals we we don't
really have a relationship with Our
obligation to the Future and I I
I I am troubled by the fact that it is
increasingly I mean even things like
light pollution cause us not to have the
reminder in the night sky of what place
we actually hold in the universe right
and I think this is getting to be a
harder and harder job that technology is
just it's everywhere you look and so we
are losing touch with what we really how
we got here
well you know um I wrote a book with a
fellow eco-feminist Maria Miss and she
has a chapter in it called from the
individual to the dividual because not
only
have we been fragmented from the
ecological Web of Life but from the
social community of life in thinking
artificially about assets little atoms
in an alien Universe when we are into
beings when we are entangled socially
generationally yeah we are entangled
ecologically
the
you know actually cultures like mine
cultures like the first nations in North
America always talked about the Seventh
Generation
that we must think of the Seventh
Generation to come and Every Act of us
should make their possibilities better
and that's one reason society's thinking
in the Seventh Generation didn't go
around trashing the planet it's when you
don't think of the species next door
your next generation your neighbor
which is the kind of selfish egoistic
self that's being created and then a
fragment itself you know I mean I feel
sad
see young people not know how to do
anything
beyond their computers yeah that's why I
encourage them to come learn farming put
your hands in the soil learn your part
of the soil learn that those soil
organisms shape you and that brings a
new humility
and it brings a new power yes I think
what's what's being bred today is a new
inferiority and from that new
inferiority a huge aggression against
others when if we remember that the word
humus is the word for soil the word
human is derived from humus
and the word humility is derived from
the same humus so we are soil we are
seed We Are soil and that is how we take
our power back
and extend like the mycorrhizal fungi
are Networks
to create the new
economy the new democracy the new
cultures that are needed
well interesting uh I know you you have
to go it's very late where you are
um very late I would uh I would point
out that there is something interesting
also your point about soil is well taken
and uh
um I'm not a believer that the Universe
sends messages but uh if it were to try
to send a message through covid it sent
a pretty strong indication of the
importance of the soil uh and our
um
politically broken order because
Ivermectin comes from soil it is the
product of a soil uh organism
and uh in the state of uttar Pradesh in
India very large State as I understand
it almost as large as the United States
is they ignore the international order
allowed people to use Ivermectin and had
spectacular success at driving back
coven you know with a soil organism so
and there is
um a a powerful indication in this of
where we really are in the universe how
much power we actually have
um and where you know where it comes
from and and where the false versions of
it are
so
um in any case uh I I resonate strongly
with your message about reconnecting
with the soil uh saving seeds planting
seeds and pondering uh the meaning of
their growth and I I wish you luck in
that campaign
thank you so much but it's lovely
meeting you lovely meeting you can you
tell
um our audience where they can find you
and where they can find your new book
well the book Terra Viva my life in a
biodiversity of movements has been
published by Chelsea Green so if you go
to Chelsea Green you'll be able to find
out how to get it I'm sure it'll be in
bookstore soon
to contact me you can write at one
Vandana dot Shiva
at gmail.com
[Music]
without the fact that the movement of
Danya we offer courses
of returning to the Earth becoming part
of a living system and you can go to
navdhania Earth University to get more
details thank you and thank you Brett
thank you so much
[Music]
foreign
[Music]